i feel like just voice acting agencies
like anywhere in any country is like you
know quite high standards but i feel
japan especially has some
pretty insane standards oh because it's
one of the most sought-after jobs in
japan
right right yeah it's a huge competition
freddie
after
[Music]
all the kids in japan are like number
one youtuber number two voiceover
well i've you know you've seen loads of
videos about it and i've like people
going into these schools and it's like a
military camp
and you feel so bad because you're like
all these people mostly people
have had their dreams crushed yeah
they're not gonna make it yeah like what
what is like the kind of
daily routine
what what is like the daily routine for
like schools like that because like
you only hear about voice acting schools
in japan but like you know obviously i
don't think any of us have been doing it
or knowing
about it i mean it depends on the school
like some schools
um you have to go there like five times
a week um some school they only have it
like
once a week and i went to one that was
only like once a week
and the teachers there will be really um
strict
and um in japanese you call it like
taika kaike it's really like
they're really strict yeah right yeah so
like um
we do like um you know accent and
pronunciation and we also do like
um what is it in english like oh like uh
so that it's like you know to fix like
lisps yeah
like be able to pronounce like all
syllables yeah yeah yeah i don't know
what it's called
i don't know pronunciation yeah
pronunciation i guess enunciation
enunciation is very very important
yeah but then um because the
teachers were like really strict like um
by like six months into starting school
like
half of the students wouldn't would
start not coming to school
right right just kind of like
disappearing
disappear right right kind of like uni
then
so is it like kind of a strict process
for even getting into this school like
you mentioned you have to audition a
bunch in your turn
yeah um this also depends on the school
like some schools are really strict um
some schools um they're not as strict
um because like you know you you learn
everything at school so like
you know i think they're looking for
like people with like nice voices or
like you know
okay people who have like potential like
kick anyone out they're like
you're terrible go home um like all the
auditions
like kind of like that i guess yeah well
it's kind of like
it comes through post like whether you
passed or not so it's like
oh yeah they want to tell you in person
yeah it's
you go to the audition and they're like
okay thank you like you know and you go
home and then like a week later
that's just such a typical like
passive-aggressive japanese yeah yeah
you're terrible goodbye yeah exactly so
how long would you typically study at
the voice acting school
um i went to uh the voice acting school
for two years some people only go for
like
a year as well you don't get any jobs in
that time it's pure like
purely um well uh for me
it was i got a job when i was at school
yeah
and um that was only because i was able
to speak english
it's not really common yeah right yeah i
get i guess you have the the advantage
of
being bilingual yeah so you get like
that
you get those english jobs yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i'm just talking to kind
of how like being bilingual
in this country or in any asian country
if you want a job in that country it's
just like so easy
it's like a cheat code almost i mean i
mean that's you know one of the big
reasons why i wanted to move here right
is because like
you know in australia no one really
gives a [ __ ] if you can speak japanese
the only job you'd probably be able to
get is like teaching japanese
like the saturday school year yeah but
it's like even then it's like a lot of
japanese teachers in australia
don't even really speak that good of
japanese yeah in an alternative timeline
you were
an interpreter for the president of
this that's probably the only one
talking to like the president of the
prime minister of japan
you just chose behind him like we're
telling him in the year
that's probably like the only like real
high-end job you could probably get yeah
japanese but like here for example like
every company in
every field is looking for someone to
speak english yeah so it's just
natural progression to just come here
yeah exactly
what i want to know is like the things
you learn in voice acting school do they
specifically teach you how to sound like
an
anime character because like because
like i've noticed obviously as
it's common sense that anime characters
sound very different from how people
usually speak right yeah
so do what goes into like learning how
to speak like that
uh this also depends on like which kind
of teacher you have but some teachers
are based like
on like acting so they're more like
instead of like you know
sounding like an anime character like
they want you to focus on your acting
skills
but some like teachers actually do like
tell you like you need to be more like
like over like over the top yeah you
know because like anime
characters they're like over the top
yeah yeah
so yeah okay so you've been in school
for two years
how does it then transition into being
like you're a professional now start
working like what
is it like a set end date at the school
or is it like
they just they're like you're ready now
kid go on start
for my school uh there was like a set
date that um you finished school
and before you finish school you'll have
like auditions to get into
the agency yeah cause i feel like
in the west they're just like all right
you're done [ __ ] [ __ ] off good luck
make it work kid yeah yeah but yeah
they'll be like you know
um staff they're like looking at you and
yeah usually you'll be handed like a
script like 15 minutes before you
actually
um act in front of the outrageous
people and so what is the point of that
because it's like that doesn't happen on
a regular journey you don't show up to
the studio not knowing what enemy you're
going to be in and being like
here's the script uh you're recording
it's really common at least in english
that you wouldn't know
you wouldn't see the script until you're
actually recording it though yeah but in
japan
i mean like for like narration or like
sometimes
there's like times when they give it to
you on on that day well like
in regards to like anime and games it's
more like you know you get like
like several days yeah because the free
planning stage for anime and games
is insanely wrong because there's
sometimes in english that's still
changing the lines
while you're getting oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so they might change them
or like maybe you know they'll change it
while you're doing the lines yeah
yeah before you guys like i don't like
this anymore i want to change it i'm
like okay
yeah because when i because when i did
the stuff for uh pop team epic
they gave me the script like like four
weeks before i actually went in yeah
so no nda either right huh no nda either
oh nda
they gave me i talked about the podcast
but they literally gave me a cd
of the episode oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah like is that just like a
common thing yeah it's like a
like like anime recordings right yeah
yeah yeah you get like a cd beforehand
and you check that at home and then you
see how long you're
like and then you kind of like check out
the timing of like when to start you
have to like sign anything saying i
won't show this to anyone
no what did the trust system here dude
yeah that's crazy